ils ont commencé
bonsoir
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir bonsoir olivier bourg soit
retirée bonsoir monsieur cad vous soit
retiré tout va bien alors 8 millions de
spectateurs pour les choristes
ah oui merci d'être là quand même ouais
ouais nan c'est cool
ouais ouais ça fait quoi d'être devenu
un monstre sacré du cinéma cad
bah je poursuis était déjà un monstre
déjà ouais donc maintenant je suis sacré
désagréments ça me fait plaisir à ce
niveau de jeu kadia qui en france lala
maintenant le niveau là ouais
abbott niveau je pense que je suis je
suis à ce niveau là je suis tout seul je
pars et ouais non mais attendez c'est
non mais faut faut le dire à un moment
donné à l'école vous l'avez vu le film
je suis désolé vous avez commandé
d'assurer un moment donné ça va hein
mais ça me gêne pour mon mari j'ai juste
pensé qu'avec contacter les autres
acteurs deviennent meilleurs oui bah
vous voyez jugnot par exemple il s'est
bien amélioré ou carrément s'asseoit
entre deux films quand il ya eu quand
même c'est pas bon pour moi je sais pas
c'est la première fois qu'ils étaient
lus millions d'entrées du niveau même
programme
alors là pour le césar c'est dans la
poche et normalement bastos car l'os 48e
alors attendez mais vous avez vu ce film
ils se foutent un peu de toi t'es sur
que décembre c'est difficile aujourd'hui
quand vous croisez deux anciens potes à
vous comme farrugia comme de la rue
ouais ouais c'est pas facile c'est un
petit peu compliqué mais évident parce
qu'on a pu le même niveau de vie
d'espérance de
deux facultés quoi tout simplement ne
pas être simple tous les jours à 5 m en
même temps voilà je suis quand même avec
le que derrière mais sympa et csaba il
ose encore vous appeler ou oui bah
maintenant ils m'appellent surtout ouais
ouais ils veulent bosser à bala ouais
c'est vrai que pour les choristes 2 vous
avez demandé 20 millions de dollars non
c'est vrai 22la c'est vrai parce que les
choristes contre les pokémon alors on
m'a dit que vous aviez joué le rôle que
tout est finalement c'est vous étiez
trop cher pour eux oui puis des
bouclettes moi ça me va pas mais selon
eux il y avait un problème de cacher
aussi dans tous les cas merci monsieur 4
d'être avec vous ce soir beaucoup
apprendre que c'est à dire merci ce soir
je vais pas partir c'est mon ami
j'ai mon ami c'est lui toni
c'est un rêve mois revient ça va ça
valide y est on est très bien oui mais
ça va quand même à autre une super ouais
j'ai vu que je viens de me réveiller
l'agent de faire un espèce de rêve où je
sais pas ce que c'était mais tu avais
joué dans les corps et c'est ça et puis
un métier pas vous poser des questions a
valu sinon tu vas ouais bah oui c'est un
bon garçon il alors que le chiffre est
un petit koné alors vous êtes ici pour
une double promo oui il ya le livre et
le dvd
oui le livre alors le livre se lit le
lit ça s'appelle sans bonne raison de
continuer à fumer bus et aux éditions du
cherche-midi belle vie d'un site une
antidote aux campagnes anti tabac qui
vient dire nous empoisonnent l'exploit
surtout qu'on a vraiment des bonnes
raisons quoi alors oui par exemple vous
êtes en surcharge pondérale deux ou
trois kilos à perdre d'accord yj les uns
en fumant vous courrez l'ablation d'un
des deux poumons au point d'un poumon 3
kg bah ouais c'est utile c'est pas de la
merde je vous fais un filtre ça mais
sentant à s'auto dégradé ouais d'accord
vous auriez grand petit bout les
goristes commence inquiet excusez-moi
filtre ça mais sentant à s'auto dégradé
vos arrières petits-enfants auront une
trace de votre existence
moi si l'homme n'avait jamais fumé en a
vendu à la radio justement gère des
projets oui c'est vrai notamment entendu
l'amour c'est comme une plaquette de
frein et les feux de forêt il y en aura
plus alors en reprenant la cigarette
vous contribuer à l'épanouissement
financier de la formule 1 c'est une
bonne action
c'est vrai rien d un apéro sans club
c'est comme un film sur l'euro en 2000
830 euros
c'est une année de cigarettes 1,1834
euros c'est une année de sport oui et
que c'est moins cher de fumée alors ça
c'est la première propose donc c'est
sans bonne raison de continuer à fumer
oui et puis notre promo le dvd la
traversée de l'atlantique en solitaire à
2 alors ça vous a pris comme ça un matin
vous aimez démarre d'humeur du showbiz
mais par delà la vie parisienne de la
drogue des [ __ ]
vous avez décidé finalement autour d'eux
surtout de la centrale ouais enfin plus
mois de la course mais moins vous avez
décidé de vivre une grande histoire à
deux ouais partir on a trouvé on a on a
eu le tendon s'est dit voilà partons sur
l'atlantique on va trouver un bateau on
a trouvé on n'a pas trouvé de sponsor
personnel eu malheureusement de
sponsoriser walemme gd donc on à
fabriquer nous mêmes la boue qui
utilisent et donc on a fait les
équilibres les kilos de purée qui va les
faire sécher ont maintenant des petits
sachets de voix on a appris à nager on a
appris à naviguer puis un jour les
partis ont des parties de roscoff en
bretagne on se dit voilà on va traverser
pour rejoindre new york c'est les quatre
mois après voilà on a ces énormes moyens
en même temps on pour être très honnête
avec vous et honnête on a été les
spectateurs je suis je crois que c'est
quand même un con ça va au départ
c'était pas pour en faire un dvd
non c'était pas pour en faire des
sketchs puisque on dit des skates m'ont
été c'est simplement une aventure
humaine qu'on avait un journal de bord
on envoyait des images au pc donc il
s'occupait d'eux
ce cafard aux caps donc à sa maman vous
été le pc de la course et à la fin bon
il s'est trouvé qu'on avait peu près 42
jours comme ça de messages images bon on
va pas laisser non plus ça dans la
nature etc ça comme ça ça va me ville
l'a fait je veux dire pourquoi nous on
ne ferait pas pourquoi est-ce qu'on
serait moins que dsk est ce que dabo
vitesse qui l'a vraiment traversé à ce
qu'il n'a pas fait en studio
est ce qu'il est parvenu à roscoff voulu
d'arrivée meilleurs moments avec cela
ouais on a regardé on va regarder à quoi
ça ressemble je les regardais votre
caméra tous les deux oui et vous allez
dire en même temps magnéto serge 3,2
mégapixels